hello everyone and welcome back to grand
masters choice tonight our grand master
in residence chose not to be here so i
national master caleb denby am filling
in with a lecture of my choosing
and tonight i want to talk about a
topic that goes really all the way to
the top of chess you know this is how
games get decided at every level of
chess magnus carlsen included it's about
decision making
you know you can calculate to the best
of your abilities you can find the truth
of the position but then it doesn't
matter if you make the wrong decision at
the end of it and so with that in mind
we're going to look at a few of my games
tonight actually and i'm going to talk
about my decision making process
and why sometimes it works and why
sometimes i end up at the wrong decision
just as we all do
so to do that i'm starting with this
game i had against international master
safal borah strong international master
safal borah
i played this game in the chicago class
of this year so not too long ago
and i was kind of unhappy with this game
after after it happened so let's let's
see what it looks like here
so i start with d4 we get knight f6
c4
g6
knight c3
and d5 so it's it's a grunfeld
um and believe it or not i had done 10
minutes of prep before this game and i
saw that's the fall borah tends to play
the green felt quite a lot so i was
ready for it
i play one of the main variations where
i take on d5 take on d5 of course the
downside to the grunfeld is that white
gets to build this nice strong center
take on c3 b take c3
bishop g7
bishop c4
and now of course the upside of the
grunfeld is black is going to get a lot
of pressure on the dark squares in white
center so black does so right away with
c5
we get knight e2 knight c6 piling on the
pressure bishop e3
castles sorry castles for black and
castles for white
and now
one of the main moves queen to c7
so the point of white's opening is that
by bringing this knight to e2 rather
than f3 we are still able to support
this dark square d4 in the center
without having to worry as much about
the move bishop g4 because we can simply
kick this bishop away now with f3 you
know compare that to with the bishop to
if the knight were on f3 then we'd have
real problems defending the dark squares
in the center here so
that's why bishop g4 while it is one of
the main moves still is not as powerful
here and why my opponent chose to go
queen c7
so i kind of blew past the opening there
but the reason for that is we didn't
really make any decisions you know i
knew i wanted to play this line going
into the game so i haven't had to make
any tough choices yet same goes for the
next move rook to c1 she's just the only
move in the position theoretically wise
i put my rook opposite the queen what's
not to love
then my opponent continues playing the
main moves with rooked d8s and i think i
surprised him a little bit with this
next move
h4
so what's the point of h4 well
i actually had all of this prepped going
in the idea of h4 is that
compared to other variations i want to
get a leg up by having my pawn further
up the board
harassing this bishop a little bit and
making my opponent choose
where to put it
so h4 and now my opponent is the first
one who has a decision to make
um i kind of knew i surprised him over
the board because he actually did stop
to think about this position for for a
little bit he you know he didn't know
off the top of his head what to do here
so what kind of choices do we think
black is going to be making and i'm
going to flip the board just for this
turn just to give you an opportunity to
think here
so put yourself
in safal borah's shoes here your
opponent just launched this move h4 at
you
and uh
try to come up with with an idea here
try to make a decision
so the first part of your decision
making process should be to come up with
one or two options so let's start there
let's find some options for black to
finish development
all right someone in the chat says why
have you got a mask on um there is a
mask mandate currently in saint louis
and we are open to the public with
hordes of people in the live audience
tonight so for their safety i will
remain masked up
all right joe bruno mysteriously says e
file
i don't know the meaning maybe he means
d file but i still don't
don't know the meaning of this
oh yeah hordes of people i'm surprised
you can't hear
hear the the crowd over there in the
chat room
so the chat is giving me some some one
move suggestions which tends to be what
the chat does but
uh to get the most out of it you know
you want to be thinking as if this were
your own tournament game that's the way
to to approach getting better at chess
through these lectures you want to
really take it seriously
you know try to put that kind of
pressure on yourself where you know any
decision you make could be the end of
the game could get you a horrible
position and that could be the end of
the story for you
so first things first you know you want
to look at some of the normal ideas so
what are the normal ideas here you know
one is to go knight a5 and c4 this is
definitely one idea another idea is to
play something like e6 try and prevent
white from playing something like d5
maybe we can go b6 and bishop b7 finish
our development uh over on the queen
side of the board
uh and now you really just have to
decide between these options
so we've come up with a few different
options for black we have this knight a5
and c4 plan
um trying to shut this light squared
bishop out of the game we have this b6
and bishop b7 plan just trying to finish
development and we have something like
e6 you know keeping things a little bit
more fluid and just uh
meeting white in the center trying to
meet white in the center
maybe another plan i failed to mention
would be e5 you know trying to really
clarify things in the center
so that's what i want to talk about
tonight you know first things first you
come up with your options but then we
have to figure out
what's the difference between all of
these and how do we decide
so of course
the tool that helps you make decisions
in chess is calculating you want to use
your calculating abilities to
make these decisions but i want
everybody listening to understand that
calculation is is not enough in this
instance calculation is a tool uh for
decision making so you can't just
calculate calculate calculate get to the
end of your calculation say yeah that's
fine i'll play that
you want to calculate your different
options and then the real trick and what
we're going over tonight is how to
decide between them so let's spend some
time calculating here so if i go knight
a5 i would argue this is maybe the most
natural option
then white of course is going to want to
save this bishop so bishop d3 makes a
lot of sense
then let's say black plays something
like c4 forces this bishop even further
back
then again black is going to be
forced to come up with another idea so
we can go knight a5 bishop d3 c4 bishop
c2 then it's black's turn again so if
you want to play 95 you should really
have another move after this and then a
justification for it
so how do we continue in that position
well maybe you know you can think you go
e5 e6 there maybe you go b5 and long
term you want to set up with bishop b7
and a6
and
attack white center
so that's one option you can go knight
a5 bishop d3 c4 bishop c2 maybe b5 or b6
put this bishop on b7
and go after white's center on the light
squares so that's one plan
now let's think more about e6 what is
our plan going to be
if we actually play this e6 move
and i'll ask the chat this one what is
our idea with e6
alexander mentions that knight e5 is
interesting
with a pretty similar idea to knight a5
taking advantage of this pin on the d
file but again
you know you use this tool of
calculation
and then uh then you decide at the end
of your calculation whether or not it's
all worth it so 95 i mean
white's gonna move i guess you might be
thinking about playing c4 here as well
you bishop back to c2 and then you can
look at something like knight g4 see if
that gets you anywhere
but actually now that i'm calculating
bishop f4
could give you some problems here so
this is how the thought process tends to
go in games you look at these different
ideas you calculate them and if
something seems reasonable
the hard part is deciding between which
one
so let me show you something in the game
sephal plays this move knight a5 this is
what he decided to do in the game
and so as predicted
i go bishop d3
and then he actually doesn't play c4
right away but
when you play knight a5 the idea is to
go c4 eventually
instead he goes b6 and decides to you
know combine these ideas c4 is going to
come eventually bishop b7 is the main
point and he's trying to attack me along
the light squares
now i'm not actually convinced that this
was the best idea for the fall i think
he made a mistake in his decision making
here
now i can't really blame him because
it's so early in the game
that without a lot of preparation in the
help of computers it's difficult to make
absolutely correct decisions uh in the
opening but i think instead he should
have gone for this idea of e6 and i'll
show you why in a moment but i think
after something like
uh
like the move h5
i think this e6 move is necessary to
help defend along these light squares so
for example if we go for 95 now again
bishop f4 comes into play but we're just
going to move the queen out of the way
again this is a useful pin then after
something like bishop b3 you can even go
b5
and the point of black's play is that
he's gotten his pieces into active
positions without really committing to
c4 yet
so now we get this interesting dynamic
where uh black is yes contesting the
dark squares in the center still and
potentially could be contesting them
even further with the move like b4 but
still has the option to uh go after some
of these light squares as well
and the reason why i think this is the
correct decision is because black's
position remains so fluid and we'll see
that the problem with safal's play after
knight a5 is that black is really sort
of put into a box here black really only
has one idea
in the game variation so i think 95
wrong decision in this case
all right sorry for the whiplash but
we're going to go back to looking for my
perspective now
because we love looking from my
perspective
okay bishop d3 b6 and now my idea i was
still kind of well within uh familiar
territory here the idea of h4 of course
is to go to h5 uh so no hard decisions
for me yet as fall continues his
development now with bishop to b7 i go
h6
and now this decision actually isn't too
hard for black at all bishop h8 and
bishop f6 just both really aren't very
good moves
and the reason for that is we need to go
bishop f8 to keep an eye on this h6 pawn
so who can tell me why why we need to
keep an eye on the h6 pawn why not just
bishop h8 keeping pressure on the center
what's the problem with this
what's the problem with this
nobody knows nobody knows the problem
with bishop h8
so yeah you guys are you guys have some
ideas here but none of them are quite
right so
um
youtube in the chat is worried about e5
kind of shutting this bishop out but i'm
not so sure that's the case e5 actually
does a lot for black's light squared
bishop and then it also gives uh what's
called a hook for black in the center
black can kind of latch onto this e5
pawn
maybe try something like f6 to to open
things back up and suddenly black is
going to have a lot of activity right
black's going to have a lot of activity
uh someone else says it limits the king
not really here not really uh but the
big idea which i don't think anybody in
the chat has kind of surprisingly
is that by not having the pressure on h6
this allows white to expand very very
freely on the king's side with with f4
and i think f4 is just going to be a
very very strong move here now the idea
of having the bishop on a fate be that
bishop takes h6 is legal after f4 now
with the bishop on h8 not so clear it
looks like i can just go f4
and now i'm going to expand everywhere
in the center d5 f5
maybe e5 but but probably not probably
f5 is is the main break i'm looking for
here with uh opening the f file and
making use of my central advantage
so fall chooses correctly with bishop f8
now i go queen to d2
still not really any hard decisions for
white here i'm just playing
um good simple chess activating my
pieces right so so nothing too too crazy
now rook a to c8 and again i just
activate my pieces with rook f to d1
and now after queen d7 um i have my
first big decision point
so i've brought all my pieces into the
center they all seem actively placed and
the question now is
how should i continue into the middle
game
so of course
first things first let's come up with
some candidate moves some options
for us to consider so
who has some ideas for a plan who has
some ideas
so supporter of peace is
still potentially saying e5
alex says d5 the other pawn push in the
center
um
knight g3 and f4 f5 is jeff's idea
and yeah this is sort of the the the
problem in the position for uh
for white is
we would love to go f4 f5 but because
the fall has made this good decision to
put the bishop on f8 it's always going
to come at a little bit of a risk and
that risk is that you know we're losing
a pawn i'm not saying it's unplayable uh
but i am saying we're losing a pawn
uh and it's so it's it's important to be
aware of this when uh suggesting these
these kind of knight g3 f4 f5 oh well
sorry can't take yet but for example
here
uh gotta be careful about this h6 pawn
um so why not e5 so e5 you don't have to
calculate very hard to see why this
isn't such
such a great move black can simply play
e6
um probably the the most natural move
just stopping any further pawn pushes
and now all of a sudden
black's bishop on b7 is very very active
and black still maintains a lot of
pressure against this d4 pawn and in
fact
you know given another move here uh
let's say f3 to try to stunt this bishop
black is probably just going to take
this open up the c file and not be very
unhappy with his position at all bishop
d5 even
and i would much rather have black in
this position
uh so e5 definitely not going to be it
and again the problem with knight g3 is
that maybe black is going to play
something like e6 just contest or
control for the d5 square
and i'm always going to be very hesitant
to play this move f4 because this h6
pawn is just going to fall
so
we use the tools of calculation we
calculate that knight g3 f4 f5 might not
be so good because we lose our h6 pawn
we calculate that e5 might not be so
good because after e6 then you know
black has ideas of taking on d4 planting
a bishop on the d5 square and we
calculate that after d5 well what's
going on here what's going on here
uh because intuitively it looks very
very good for white we stunt this light
squared bishop for black we keep this
knight on a5 out of the game
and it looks like you know black is on
the back foot but we still have to
calculate so of course what is black's
idea after d5 what do we have to
calculate here
what do we have to calculate
so yeah you guys in the chat are right
e6 is the critical idea to look for
against d5 again
uh much much earlier when e5 was
adjusted i mentioned that f6 might be a
good way to you know latch onto the hook
on e5 and same with d5 e6 is going to be
the main thing to look out for now of
course calculating we can see a very
strong response to e6 if black were to
try it right away that of course is the
move c4 you know and and now our pawn
structure is just way too solid this
bishop is has already been ejected from
the h8a1 diagonal so it's even stronger
than it would normally be it's knights
out of the game the bishop's out of the
game and taking doesn't really
accomplish much of anything here for
black
so
of course the idea must start with c4 as
someone else in the chat mentioned
and now we have to think about the
ramifications of e6
so this is where calculation comes into
play you see the balance you use the
tool of calculations to make informed
decisions in your games
and joe in the chat you're killing me
this is the d file i promise it's the d
file
promise it's not the e file
all right jeff in the chat is saying can
c4 be met with b5 well one of the
problems there is that your your
knight's under attack and that might
seem like a superficial problem
until you realize
the knight can't move and it's not so
easy to defend um so b5 that would be
the
thematic break but uh it's not so easy
in that position white is just just
winning
joe's really sticking with his e-file
storyline here really sticking with the
e-file story trust it
okay so nobody knows nobody knows what's
going on after e6
so this is where calculation is really
really uh really important
e6 uh there's quite simply i think a
winning uh
winning idea here for white we can just
take on e6 and now if we take on d2 we
take on f7 with check
and take back and and we've just won a
pawn it's that easy
and of course if queen takes e6 we're
actually not at all afraid to give give
up our queen
for these two rooks
because again this pawn on h6 is taking
away a lot of squares from the black
king and the rooks are just going to be
very very very strong in this position i
think the only move to stay in the game
is something like like knight c6
otherwise if you get a little bit greedy
i'm gonna be able to take and bring my
other rook in the game
um very very scary stuff very scary
stuff maybe even rook a8 with the
similar ideas
um and knight c6 i'm going to go knight
d4 this is an important move forking the
the knight in the queen
and here the problem for black again is
just that this pawn takes away so so
many squares i have total control over
the d file and uh white i i think is
just winning here
so
going back to this decision you know we
don't really like e5 knight g3 is
definitely a good consideration
but i don't see the the real follow-up
after it um
and after d5 it seems like things are
working out in our favor it seems pretty
promising
so in a tournament situation it's
important to balance the amount of time
you spend calculating with your time
management of course time is not an
infinite resource in tournament chess
games and so that's enough that's enough
you see that d5 looks promising you
don't really like your other options and
so i commit to the change i commit to
the change in structure i play the move
d5 and never look back
so in the game so fall
continues with c4 again i think this
move is forced otherwise c4 is very very
strong for white
we go bishop c2
and now he surprises me with the move
queen to e8
and this is the power
of super strong chess players
um and that's why the class is on
decision making tonight this move right
here i think queenie8
is sort of a brilliant idea
of course e6 is just bad for black and
maybe you know you play queen e8 because
you see that nothing else works
but let me tell you why i think 28 is
such a brilliant move
it's because it gives white a decision
and this is how stronger players beat
players like myself lowly national
masters they keep giving you decisions
you know they say okay you might have a
good position but now i'm going to let
you decide how you want to play it you
know people might think that's a high
level chess is about sort of just
rolling over your opponent with forcing
moves and out calculating them
but really high level chess is about
correct decision making and this is
where safal borah has me beat he's just
better at decision making than i am and
that's why this game is about to take a
turn
so here we already know black's idea
black wants to play e6 the problem is we
have a lot of different options for how
we want to deal with it
so i will turn the question to you chat
how do you want to deal with black's
idea of playing e6
how can we deal
someone also mentioned that bishop g5 is
an important idea i think they were
mentioning it in the event of e6 rather
than queen eight but that remains an
important idea here
so great wolf asks is queen e8 sort of
like a nothing move and definitely not
the idea is that now rather than having
a queen opposite our queen to rook
opposite our queen so e6 is very much a
real threat now because
we're never going to be able to take
like we could in the other variations
so queen eight while it does have an
idea and has uh a threat so to speak
uh the point is white has different
options for how to deal with it and it's
these decision points this is where the
evaluations of these chess games tend to
change because you know any lowly
national master can find an only move or
two if i only have one move to stay in
the game more often than not i like to
think at least i'm gonna be able to find
it but when i have five different
options that all look reasonable i it's
much less clear if i'm going to be able
to find the best one
and that's why decision making is so
important
okay let's see what the chat is saying
somebody in the chat likes the move
queen e1 sort of taste of his own
medicine there
um
bishop g5 has been mentioned and bishop
g5 has one very concrete problem so my
advice to you is if you like bishop g5
think about black's response to it a
little bit remember we have our
candidates but you do have to calculate
them a little bit as well
doesn't take much calculation to see why
bishop g5 might not be working
okay matthew futch comes up with the
idea putting a knight onto d4
and
matthew has one of those names where i
thought like uh it was a bart simpson
deal where i was getting pranked for a
second but i don't think i said anything
bad i think that's just his name
okay knight d4 seems like a good idea so
so what's the point of knight d4 what's
the point
knight d4 is one of the main options
and yeah by the way the chat has figured
it out the problem with bishop g5 here
is that you're going to get met with
this awkward move f6
and you might be thinking to yourself
well you know i'm hap i'm happy if i
force my opponent to play f6 i know what
ben feingold says
but the problem here is that if you
retreat the bishop uh really anywhere uh
you're gonna get met with g5 and this
pawn on h6 is just hanging even if you
come all the way back to e3 again g5 and
black is able to activate by by
capturing this pawn
so that's why i know bishop g5
but knight d4 is one of the main options
so we have knight d4 and queen e1 as our
options so far there's one more
that i would like you guys to find one
more critical option here
before we start our serious calculations
one more important idea someone says
queen d4 this one doesn't really make
sense to me you know it doesn't solve uh
solve the problem right you still have
this problem here
of the rook
hitting the queen
so yeah joe bruno has the last idea
although he insists that this is the e
file i promise it's not he says bishop
e4 of course he means bishop d4
d as in dog
and so that's our third idea so we have
knight d4 bishop d4 and queen e1 and now
we have to do some calculating to to
find out which one uh which ones are
good and which ones are not good so
let's start with this move knight d4
what's the point of knight d4 what are
you doing against
black's idea of e6
what's to be done here
so hassan says what a bishop d4 that's
one of our options but we're starting
with knight d4 so we have three really
nice candidate moves
okay we have three good candidate moves
now we need to use the tool of
calculation
to uh
to see what we've got see what we've got
going on
okay someone says bishop g5 but okay um
just so you guys know whenever you play
bishop g5 i'm playing bishop b7 so you
can't end the line there can't really
end the line there
of course i mean after e6 otherwise f6
would be strong but yeah bishop g5 but
should be seven and not too much is
different
not too much is different
not saying it's a bad move but it's not
the end of the line by any means
okay youtube says just take the pawn so
black takes back i mean give me more
give me more
okay littleface says bishop g5 bishop e7
f4 so
you know e6 was a threat for a reason
right if you don't do anything about it
i'm taking your d-pawn for free
so harsh
uh
says that we should take on e6 and then
just go queenie to unpinning
so
that is a reasonable place to stop
calculating but
uh when you stop calculating you then
have to evaluate the positions so let's
say you know we go remember we're
thinking from here by the way we're
thinking from here so we're saying
knight d4 is one of our big options and
then our idea is that if e6 we take on
e6 f takes e6 and then we go queen e2
so the question is how much do you like
your position after queen e2 do you like
it a lot do you like it a little
um
do you not like it at all
how do we feel that's the last step in
decision making you can calculate until
there's no more threats in the position
but then you have to decide how much you
like it and that can be the tricky part
maxwell says he's not a huge fan after
the move e5 for black in that final
position so it's good to go a step
further and say okay so maybe e5 he
attacks my knight looks like knight f3
is the only move there i don't see any
other squares for the knight
and then we have to evaluate again so
how do we evaluate
harsh with eddie likes it a lot for
white
likes it a lot for white
okay so
the the thing is let me tell you how i
like to evaluate positions and
you know i'm i'm no international
masters of albora
but the thing to do
is to look at you know yes specific
moves in your calculations but also when
you're getting to the end of your line
you just kind of want to evaluate okay
so let's take stock of things in this
variation i'm going to go ahead and put
it on the board for you guys so you
don't have to visualize quite so much so
we're saying e6 d takes e6 f takes e6 is
really the only move now we were worried
about this idea of e5 so queen e2 is
suggested i quite like this move
and then we were saying uh maybe e5 for
black to kick us off of this d4 square
and then knight f3 and the question is
how much do we like white's position
here do we like it or not like it or is
it just okay
and the thing is in the game i was not
really thrilled about this variation i
actually did get this far calculating in
my head but remember calculating it's
just a tool you also have to evaluate
and decide on your on your positions
or decide between your lines
so why didn't i like this so much for
white well i thought by getting rid of
my d5 pawn black would be able to pretty
easily reroute his pieces back into the
game and this was my main concern with
going for this position i thought that
you know
black is going to be able to play
something like bishop c6 and knight b7
and bring this knight maybe out to d6
and uh with these ideas in minds he's
he's just uh
doing okay like i didn't see any reason
why should be too much better yes this
e5 pawn is probably a target yes i have
some space on the king's side but i
didn't really see how to make it work
so that's why i kind of decided against
this line with knight d4 i got the
feeling that maybe white should be
slightly better
but when i was evaluating at the ends
you know i saw a clear way for black to
get into the game and i wasn't so sure
how to continue with white
so i saw knight d4 i calculated it i
wasn't super happy so let's talk about a
different line then let's talk about
queen e1 is this the answer that white
is looking for so let's calculate now a
little bit after queen e1
uh what are we doing against black's
idea of e6 this is really black's only
idea i would argue
so what's the plan here
chess king says d takes e6 of course in
this case i think we're taking back with
the queen though
rather than the pawn
maybe now f3 says chess king
and yeah i mean f3 is a perfectly fine
move and we're looking now again
and it seems like yeah maybe maybe white
should be better here this looks simple
enough we've got a nice solid structure
still have this extra space on the
king's side but again it doesn't really
look like it's a crushing attack for
white or anything
it doesn't really look like a crushing
attack
so queenie1 seems like a viable option
bishop d4 was our last idea but just to
recap knight d4 it seems like it goes
okay it seems like we get a pretty
reasonable position looks kind of good
for white because black structure is
fractured and we have this extra
kingside space
but i wasn't totally impressed queen e1
also seems to be very very playable for
white but also not not the most
impressive in the world and so then i
started looking at bishop d4 as well so
bishop d4 what's the idea against e6
what's the idea here
and while jaime is ahead of me in the
chat he says queen f4
bishop e7
d takes e6 d takes e6 queen e5 with some
nasty ideas
uh and this was what i was thinking in
the game i was calculating this and i
was starting to think hey maybe i'm just
kind of winning the game um i don't even
think you need to go dxe6 by the way
just just queen e5 here
and it's looking uh looking pretty nasty
for black if i do say so myself
so i was calculating bishop d4 and i saw
that e6 was no longer a good move
and in my mind sort of thinking e6 was
was all black really had to go for here
so
in the game i calculated bishop d4 and i
was thinking
now black has to go e5 otherwise queen
f4 is just a very very strong move
and i thought it would be very very
clever here to just retreat my bishop
and what was the point of everything
well the point is black no longer has
this idea of playing e6 because the pawn
is on e5 then my pawn on d5 is going to
be there forever and ever and it's going
to lock these black pieces out of the
game i'm going to have a very free
free hand on the king's side of the
board and i thought that i was
going to be cruising in this variation
so
in the game i actually spent quite a bit
of time after queen e8s and i decided to
play bishop d4
now who in the chat wants to tell me how
wrong i am because i was so so wrong in
the game
so
spoilers if you want to try and find the
correct answer yourself try to find out
why bishop d4 is wrong go ahead and
pause the video i don't often say that
anymore but this is a really interesting
position i feel
but of course
that was your spoiler warning knight d4
is gonna be the best option for us here
and the reason for that is just because
in the exact position we were talking
about
um here
there's just too many weaknesses for for
black to comfortably deal with here like
you know maybe you're going um
uh let's see
let's see what are you even playing here
it's tough
uh let's say you go bishop c6 after all
trying to go for these kinds of ideas
i'm just going to play knight h2 and i
think someone in the chat mentioned this
idea
and now the point is we're coming into
g4
the king is looking very very unsafe on
the g8 square and we're gonna have a
pretty comfortable game attacking on e5
and just when the moment's right we
might even consider playing f4 to really
break things open in in this game
um but just for example one line might
be queen g4 queen e6 queen g4
rookie 8 queen h4
and okay maybe queen g3 first to stop
issue b7 and now just kind of invading
just invading putting pressure on the
weaknesses and enjoying a very
comfortable game for white if you're
looking for a computer evaluation um
it's pretty close to plus plus two here
plus 1.5 depending on how long the
engine thinks
so very very good for white and i think
that this would have just been an easy
advantage for me and this is really what
i should have uh should have gone for in
the game
now
um
the game instead
i think queen e1 is sort of just a worse
version of this knight d4 stuff we would
much rather have black take back with
this f pawn rather than the queen so if
you want to go for this idea knight d4 i
think is is the correct move here
now there is sort of a move that's uh i
didn't mention which is this f4 idea
turns out this move might be quite good
as well uh e6 is strong but then we're
going knight d4 again and
things get really really messy here but
this might might also be good for white
however i think kind of by far this is
the least human approach because just
giving up this h pawn doesn't feel like
the right track and then e takes d5 you
have to go e5 here we're sacrificing a
lot of pawns as white we're sacrificing
a lot of pawns uh even though it is
still good
it's a lot of pawns to sacrifice for no
reason so knight d4 is my pick for the
best practical move uh instead of course
i play bishop d4 and go bishop back to
e3
and i missed my opponent's super strong
idea here
so uh if you want to try to find it go
ahead and pause but we are
moving at a snail's pace so let's keep
things moving of course black is just
going to play the strong move f6
and i missed this in the game i didn't
really see that black could play f6 here
with the simple idea of playing g5 and
capturing my pawn on h6 so turns out my
h6 pawn is just gonna die now because i
did not go for this knight d4 idea uh so
sad so since my h pawn is dying anyways
i decided to get some counter play in
the center with f4 we get bishop takes
h6 f takes e5 these decisions weren't
too hard for me in the game this is sort
of the only natural way to play bishop
takes e3 queen takes e3
queen takes e5
and then again i i calculated this from
from afar i think queen h6 is the best
try for white here
with the point being that's the slightly
tempting sacrifices stuff like bishop d5
just aren't really going to work out for
black here because i can calculate this
you know i i may not be an international
master but but even i can calculate this
should be good for white
uh same with the ideas like f5 here
we're just going to take and take and
and black is just just sort of getting
destroyed here so queen h6 important
move to unpin from this stuff and deal
with these threats with the king said
attack
however my opponent of course does also
see all this and he just plays the nice
move rook c7
now i bring the knight into d4
and he plays rook to e7
so even here i felt like i was still
doing pretty well you know i maintained
my central pawns i'm keeping these
pieces out of the game and i felt like i
should have some pressure on the king's
side so i continue now with rook to f1
we get rook out to f8
um and then i continue with rook f3
bishop c8 or cf1 just doubling up
against this f pawn here now after rook
e to f7
it's time to start making some decisions
again so i i played a lot of natural
moves there
um there were some small decisions to be
made but these moves were all natural
you know you double up on the f file you
put pressure on the pawn it all makes
sense
so the question now is
you know my opponent is defending
and he's giving me some time again to
pretty much do whatever i want which is
the scariest thing against a strong
player you never want to be able to do
whatever you want because whatever you
want is usually wrong
so the question is here how do we keep
the pieces flowing with whites what are
some options for us let's let's practice
our decision making one more time
and wow the chat room still just doesn't
seem to realize that there are
ones of people in the room with me
all right come on guys we're looking at
the looking at the chest here looking at
the chest no moves look good that's
unfortunate jordan that's unfortunate
um and it turns out that you know
white really isn't better anymore
in the game i felt like i might be
better
but uh
i was wrong it's just equal chess is a
draw
joe's ready to resign feels bad no
nobody believes in my
position look at my strong center
i have the biggest center in the world
how can you not love it
so great wolf is on the right track here
he says pieces look good except for the
bishop on c2 and that's really why white
isn't better in this position so
i was thinking along the same lines so
we we have a goal in mind our goal is to
improve our bishop on c2 now the
question is how
and you know the answer i came up with
was was
very very wrong and that's why i end up
in a worse position
the question is how so let's come up
with some candidates for how to improve
this bishop
hey the chat says rook f4
i guess you're saying you're defending
this pawn so the bishop can move but
like what's what's your point how are
you improving the bishop
bishop d1 i mean is is that improving
the bishop is the bishop better on that
square than c2 i'm not sure
it needs to contribute to our attack
somehow
it needs to contribute to the attack
okay rookie 3 has been suggested so
what's the idea of of rookie three
okay harsh with elderly says rook f4
knight f3 i think you might lose a pawn
there though gotta be careful
rook f2 knight f3 again you gotta look
out your c3 pawn is not invincible
so the correct idea here is in fact this
nice move rook to e3 this is how white
can stay in the game
um but the idea very much is is not to
go
um bishop d1 because the bishop really
isn't much better on the d1 square like
yes it's more open but it's not
contributing at all it's not
contributing here
so our idea is to sort of combine what
some other chatters were saying and now
go with knight f3 point being that a
rook is is helping to defend the
the pawn on c3
and now
after the queen moves out of the way
of course what's our idea
here what's the point how does this help
us improve the bishop
what was the point of it all yes e5 says
great wolf and that's absolutely correct
uh we want to go e5 we want to rip open
this diagonal and activate our bishop
like this now we do have to be a little
bit careful uh there's no capturing this
pawn or anything even with the rook i
think you run into some problems
but you can't just go rookie one here
and now the point is
our pieces are coming in and coming to
life here coming to life our bishop is
finally on a nice open diagonal and we
can continue the attack now
unfortunately for white black's pieces
are also pretty active and he's defended
well he's got the open f file he's got
this open diagonal over here
and
the knight is ready to to come back into
play as well so uh a balanced position
but this was the correct idea uh the
correct way to activate the bishop and i
actually did see this in the game
but in the game
i thought that maybe i could have even
better of course i was sorely mistaken
and my idea was to go with queen h4
bishop d7 or g3
and now after knight b7 finally bringing
this knights uh into the game
uh i wanted to crush my opponent with
knight to f5
the killer move knight f5 and what's the
point
the point is we come rook f5 and after
the queen moves we push through with e5
and uh
i calculated all of this
and i thought that this position would
be better for me uh when of course you
know i as i was playing it over the
board i started to realize
you know things were actually uh fading
quite fast for the white pieces here
this was just the wrong way to go
so again
my opponent made me make multiple
difficult decisions this game the first
one being this choice what to do after
queen e8 i failed that test so my
opponent got an equal position
and then finally here
um i failed the test of how to activate
my bishop i make the wrong decision and
that is why safal borah ends up with a
very good position in this game uh let's
see how it happens though so e5 f takes
e5 what else for black i go rook
f to g5 and i thought that this looked
kind of scary for black with all my
pieces bearing down on the g6 pawn but
he stays cool calm and collected just
plays rook g7 defends against the threat
and now i'm i'm really running out of
ideas
in the game i try to take on c4 but now
black's
black's pieces are active
and he again shuts the door on my bishop
and now it's very very clear that black
is is just winning in this position not
much left to do
in the game i tried rook five to g4 then
queen e5 rookie three trying to take
this pawn but after h5
i'm actually kind of forced to give up
the exchange here
if i try to go something like uh rook h4
rook g to f7 is just already
so so bad for me like uh rook f1 is is
kind of coming
and
it's just not pretty it's just not
pretty so i give up the rook
and then lost this end game sort of
without a fight
my opponent's strong enough
that's i'm not going to give him any
trouble here
tried one last trick here bishop takes
g6 but of course my opponent saw it all
coming has the nice move king h6
and then i resigned
in either this position or this position
to this position i i don't remember
um so what was the point of this long
game of course we spent quite a long
time
on this game but the point is
you see where the evaluation starts to
flip it's not because my opponent made
some crazy strong move it's because my
opponent played
a very flexible move queen to e8 you
know is saying simply i want to play e6
and it gives me so many options i have
so many different options to choose from
and now the reason my opponent is higher
rated than me is because he can select
between those options more accurately he
can calculate more accurately evaluate
more accurately and make that decision
more accurately
so that is the uh
the thing that you really need to train
to get much much better at chess it's
this decision-making process being able
to calculate evaluate and decide between
your options all in a timely manner not
an easy feat so again this this position
very very difficult decision how do we
continue how do we stop e6 and then
again
all these moves were great
uh
this position
how do we activate this bishop the
correct way is to go rook e3 knight f3
and attack down the center and my way
just total failure um
because
it gives up too much it just gives up
too much giving up the e pawn
for a nothing attack on the king's side
and then my opponent quickly and
decisively takes over the game
okay
so questions on
uh on this game and on decision making
in general we do have a few minutes left
so i might show you one more position
but uh questions on this
harshwavetti asks why did i eliminate
knight d4 in the game
and uh the answer is i didn't really
eliminate it i thought it was a good
option for white i correctly evaluated
that white would be doing kind of well
after knight d4
the problem is that i just mis-evaluated
bishop d4 so so much because i missed
this f6 idea i thought here white was
was close to winning so i you know i
thought i could do better than knight d4
it's not that i didn't like knight d4
just thought that i could do better
why are gms so good at making decisions
and this is where you know gm's they're
good at calculating so they see
everything the way it actually is
they're good at evaluating so when they
get to the end of their calculation they
can decide how good the line is quite
accurately
and they're good at time management too
for for the most part for the most part
so they're able to do this quickly and
responsibly enough that they don't spend
all their time on the first decision
they leave themselves time
for for later decisions as well
um okay
so i don't think there's too many more
questions
in this position
um so i'm gonna show you one more thing
at the uh
you know at the at the dismay of
producer ben simon so i want to show you
uh this much lower quality game uh
compared to the one that i just did
uh against
a select chess student so of course we
have a select chess program at the st
louis chess club for talented youth in
the area who are interested in chess and
i played a nice training game against
one of the students uh recently
and we had this position
so the question here is
how do we want to continue with white
there's actually quite a lot of options
and in the game i i found it quite
interesting because i made
definitely the wrong decision so this is
the puzzle i'm going to leave you with
tonight
so for those of you at home go ahead and
pause get a good feel for what's going
on in this position and see what what
you can what you come up with
and for those of you watching live
take just a minute or two here
and french eno asks while you're
thinking about it french eno asks uh is
it all about the depth of their
calculations what about intuition so
that's the the first part you have to
decide on candidate moves which is
usually led by intuition you have to
calculate them accurately calculate the
options
um and then you have to evaluate the the
final positions that you calculate and
that has a lot to do with with intuition
as well so tuition is sort of involved
in
um you know
finding the moves to calculate and
evaluating the positions afterwards
okay so everybody and their grandmother
wants to play the move c5 and this move
i think is quite bad actually this move
is is not so good now why is it not so
good well black's going to move out of
the way if you try to go b4 you know i
might just go a5 and you might have some
very serious trouble here
down the a file you know a3 is not going
to quite work out for you
if you think you're getting away with
playing b5 here that might be true
now i'm going to go knight c6
and this e5 move might might pack a
punch you might regret uh
having this weakness on c5 in and maybe
even better than than e5
is just going to be the simpler
way of playing with with b6
so got to be careful with the c5 move
you don't really want to let up on the
tension on the d5 square
so aside from that i'm getting a lot of
a
lot of single move answers um and some
of them are even correct but the point i
wanted to get across here is you know we
have a few different ways of approaching
this very complicated position in the
center one option is definitely to go
knight e5
and continue through with f4 cementing
our knight on the e5 square
one option is uh you know to maybe move
this knight out of the way continue with
f3 and e4 one option is to just let this
position sit on the in the center you
know just develop normally with both
sides play something like rook c1 and
continue
and so i found this position really
interesting because there's so many
different ways
to to approach the center now it turns
out the best way might actually be to go
knight e5
and can you continue through this f4
idea just cementing this knight but in
the game i wasn't so happy with it
because i thought this might this
knights might actually just land back
here on the e4 square and i wasn't
entirely happy about that so in the game
i came up with knight f to d2 and i
found this position to be to be very
interesting as well so black continues
now with knight d7
and my idea was to go f3
and if this knight retreats you know
consider uh coming all the way through
now with something like e4 and i thought
that's uh this would be really
interesting in the center of the board
but my opponent correctly plays knight
takes d2 knight takes d2
and now interestingly enough you know
again my opponent doesn't make the
mistake when i am you know making a
threat to the knight
he finds the correct move knight takes
d2 but he makes the mistake afterwards
he has options and options are very very
scary in chess and he makes the wrong
decision you know he should have played
something like e5 striking in the center
but other moves like c5 moves like f4
was like knight f6 probably floating
around in his head and so instead he
makes the wrong choice with f4 and now
white is simply better after e3
and f4 with a firm grip on the center
once again
so i i wanted to leave you with this
position just to show you how even you
know at all levels of chess
high quality games low quality games
decision making is a very very relevant
factor that's the idea i want to hammer
home here it's not just about finding a
tactic it's not just about positional
understanding it's about using tactics
using understanding using calculation in
order to make good decisions that's what
chess is decision making and okay with
all of that in mind i want to thank all
of you in the live audience and on
youtube very much for joining me here
tonight um as always it's a pleasure to
sub in on these youtube classes my name
is caleb denby and i will see you next
time
[Music]
you